yeah welcome to this video playing
international acetate from the from the
US playing an English opening i think is
some well known for some aggressive
style of play are here there are many
interesting ways this is what I played a
long time ago with bishop 22 g5 this is
an interesting trend an interesting line
the idea is that after this white um can
put the Queen on the some active active
post and you have some interesting
tactical ideas like Bishop g4 now for
example but damn it's not really
bleeding too much it should before I can
even play a five but I can get rid of
them the bishops and maybe hope to
exploit his some pawn structure in this
position what about taking with the poem
and using the g file wait wait wait if i
take with the Queen this is this double
attack right a8 and FF 6 yeah this is
just much better and i also have clean
air night Eve form this is some also
better than just taking f6 taking it end
in the process get rid of from the e7
bishop ok but it's probably not not yet
winning or anything but ok short castles
it do it goes into the G file but
you cannot have everything yeah I
thought combe boo Knight f3 I thought
but it's not so clear yeah not sure if I
want to play b3 really this looks are
really lame but maybe it's good anyway
going to be 70 could be a spin this next
move
hmm now I can play a three that's really
nothing happening okay
yeah I know it look look some look
slightly passive but he really doesn't
do have any substantial Fred okay yeah
let's take it knight c6 strong if I kick
this knight c6 it's just a strong post
Wow why didn't I didn't really look at
at the g-tube on it so maybe it's not so
terrible but didn't really look at this
I don't think it's really a problem
though I can take these six I can also
just take it seven by the way take a
seven-night f1 that's not it's not
completely convincing probably I can
take that though it's roop the eight
made and if he takes on g2 king edge one
I mean there's lots of stuff hanging and
I also threatened rookie one yeah yep
and now just take check and crew p 1 and
then that's this is too much night hangs
and if the night moves the rock is gone
what is slippery slippery guy
hmm crazy
crazy rabbit ok it's it's it's still
good but still a strange strange game
probably missing tons of good
possibilities
what does he trying to do we have this
one one of those those tricks on 93 or
something you have the problem is i'm
down on 20 seconds
check check check I'm morning check yeah
to lose this is a really a bit a bit
heartbreaking yeah yeah what do what on
earth did I do with my time again and
again epic it's just it's just a better
ending all the way and simply yeah yeah
I can probably just take a five and it's
it's gone yeah of course I can just take
it yeah I wanted to play it somewhat
safer I know this guy is playing for
four tricks anyway all the time and yeah
this is computer actually says it's
still winning even now on I 2685 Winston
yeah well sometimes you should just
trust your instinct that this is just a
silly trick I was I was worried about
just to put it on the board yeah i was i
was slightly worried about this with
night h 1 h 2 f1 h 2 yeah but that's
probably nothing happening anyway i can
just push the a part of course stupid I
have I just have to pawn I mean he can
go here but I
backward check now and what what is I
can even drop back on a three if
everything else fails yeah this was
stupid dad I also suspect that somewhere
in this complications why should
flat-out win but okay it doesn't help
but the end yes thanks for watching